.
WE'LL WATCH CLOSELY AND 29 DAYS.
KARI LAKE THANK YOU.
NOW TO A SHOCKING POLITICAL
DEVELOPMENT OUT OF THE STATE OF
NEW YORK, REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE
FOR GOVERNOR LEE ZELDIN IS DOWN
TO LESS THEN TWO POINTS AGAINST
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR KATHY HOCHUL
IN A VERY LIBERAL STATE OF
NEW YORK.
THIS COULD BE THE BIGGEST
POLITICAL UPSET THAT SELECTION
YEAR IN THE MAKING.
ONE BIG REASON, VIOLENT CRIME
OUT-OF-CONTROL ALL OVER
NEW YORK STATE.
KATHY HOCHUL DOESN'T SEEM TO
CARE.
SHE CONTINUES WITH DEFUND,
DISMANTLE, NOBEL LAWS.
AND SHE WANTS TO HAVE A
LISTENING TOUR PECANS INSTEAD.
AND WE HAVE LAX PROSECUTION FOR
THE STATES REPEAT OFFENDERS, IN
SPITE OF RISING CRIME ALL OVER
THE STATE.
SHE DIDN'T SEEM TO CARE WHEN HER
OPPONENT WAS VICIOUSLY ATTACKED
AND STAGED BY MEN WITH A WEAPON
THAT COULD'VE KILLED HIM.
AND SHE REFUSED TO PROVIDE
REQUESTED STATE SECURITY.
PERIOD ON SUNDAY, TWO PEOPLE
WERE SHOT RIGHT OUTSIDE
LEE ZELDIN'S LONG ISLAND HOME IN
AN APPARENT GANG GETTING HIT
WHILE TWIN DAUGHTERS WERE HOME.
WHEN THE VICTIMS WAS FOUND UNDER
THE SULTAN'S PORCH, ANOTHER IN
THE BUSHES, HIS BUSHES.
HERE WITH MORE IS LEE ZELDIN.
FIRST, THIS IS TO ATTACKS, WOW,
I WOULD THINK THE GOVERNOR WOULD
PROVIDE YOU WITH SECURITY.
NUMBER TWO I'M GLAD YOU'RE OKAY.
COULD THIS BE CONNECTED TO
POLITICS OR DO YOU BELIEVE THE
ANALYSIS OF OTHERS THAT THIS IS
LIKELY GANG-RELATED AND NOT
RELATED POLITICALLY AT ALL TO
YOU?
>> SUFFOLK COUNTY
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS TOLD ME THAT
THIS WAS NOT RELATED TO ME, NOT
A TARGET OF MY FAMILY ARE MY
HOME.
I DON'T HAVE INFORMATION TO
REBUT WHAT THE SUFFOLK COUNTY
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS TOLD ME.
SO I'M GOING WITH WHAT THEY TOLD
ME FOR NOW.
>> Tucker: HOW DID NEW YORK,
THE CRIME IN NEW YORK IT'S
OUT-OF-CONTROL AND WHY DOES THE
GOVERNOR REFUSED TO CHANGE
COURSE AND DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
YOU CAN WIN THE STATE OF
NEW YORK?
ARE THE POLLS SHOWING THAT THIS
IS A REAL RACE.
>> I'M NOT HERE TO COME IN
SECOND.
I'M IN A CAMPAIGN THROUGHOUT THE
STATE PAID ONE OF THE REASONS I
GOT INTO THE STATE IS BECAUSE OF
THESE PRO-CRIMINAL LAWS THAT ARE
GETTING PASSED OUT OF ALBANY
RELEASING PEOPLE EARLY FROM
PRISON.
PRISON STAFF BEING ASSAULTED
MORE SINCE THE IMPLEMENTATION.
WE'VE SEEN IT WITH DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS LIKE ALVIN BRAGG
REFUSING TO ENFORCE THE LAW.
THE DEFUND MOVEMENT IS ATTACKING
LAW ENFORCEMENT THEY WANT TO DO
IT NEXT STATEWIDE.
I BELIEVE ALBANY NEEDS TO BREAK
THIS AND HAVE AN UNBALANCED
POWER.
GIVING JUDGES DISCRETION AND
UTILIZING THE CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY, I WOULD SAY
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY OF THE
GOVERNOR TO REMOVE THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WHO REFUSES TO ENFORCE
THE LAW.
MY FIRST ACTION, FIRST DAY IN
OFFICE, IS TO TURN TO ALAN BRAGG
TO LET THEM KNOW IF HE'S FIRED.
>> Hannity: THIS'LL BE A
POLITICAL EARTHQUAKE THAT
SELECTION YEAR IF YOU WIN AND